mon invité pour parler des meilleurs
techniques puis comment on peut faire
pour apaiser la vie de ces gens-là Louis
Odet que vous connaissez bien président
du conseil d'administration maintenant
de la Mission Old drawing qui fait
partie de l'ADN de Montréal monsieur
bonsoir bonsoir Monsieur roi c'est une
de Cogeco bien sûr là vous arrivez comme
président du conseil d'administration
d'une institution Montréal parce que
c'est une notion qui veut grandir on va
voir des chiffres à l'écran déjà on aide
beaucoup de gens de passage c'est un
gîte également pour la nuit mais vous
voulez agrandir vous voulez on voit les
chiffres là c'est 332 lits disponibles
20 000 personnes qui passent vous avez
on veut en faire plus oui alors disons
pour se situer là on offre des services
d'urgence avec
475 lits ça ce sont des lits d'urgence
dans des Dr mais nous opérons également
336 logements environ
le 2/3 d'entre eux sont des logements
dans des édifices où les propriétaires
acceptent de l'origine notre clientèle
et l'autre tiers c'est des logements que
nous avons bâti au fil du temps et nous
continuerons en bâtir cette année nous
sommes en train d'en bâtir un autre sang
et l'idée ici c'est d'accueillir les
gens qui sont en détresse et de les
aider à passer à une autre étape dans
leur vie de les aider à se trouver un
emploi de les aider à apprendre à avoir
un chez soi
et éventuellement les gens peuvent voler
de leur propre aile et c'est bien sûr
l'objectif c'est ça qu'on veut c'est ce
qu'on veut mais en attendant on dit puis
je lisais encore ce matin à Laval il
manque de place dans les refuges c'est
exact il manque de place
voyez un organisme comme le nôtre qui
est le plus grand à Montréal qui compte
à peu près 350 membres du personnel
on ramasse à peu près on a besoin de 14
millions de dollars par année 7 millions
nous viennent des gouvernements l'autre
7 millions il faut le trouver alors il
faut demander l'aide des citoyens mais
surtout l'entreprise privée l'entreprise
privée a un gros rôle à jouer là-dedans
pour donner moi j'ai eu le plaisir de
diriger la campagne de financement en
2015 on a réussi à ramasser à peu près
30 millions là cette année on va lancer
une campagne d'environ 50 millions mais
ça c'est largement
l'entreprise privée et les fondations
qui amènent les feuilles ça c'est des
fonds d'exploitation là c'est pas des
fonds de capital mais compte tenu des
besoins puis malheureusement le besoin
ont augmenté est-ce que les deux grandes
familles le gouvernement et des
entreprises privées doivent en faire
davantage il y a aucun doute il y a
aucun doute qu'il faut en faire
davantage voyez-vous là le recensement
on n'a pas les chiffres on connaît déjà
la réponse au moins dans la grandeur il
y a 6000 personnes en situation au
Québec dont la moitié sont à Montréal
mais si vous faites la somme des lits
disponibles vous n'avez pas 3000 à
Montréal vous en avez peut-être
1000 quelque chose comme ça alors c'est
pas suffisant et on dépend beaucoup des
subventions du gouvernement fédéral et
dans une moindre mesure du gouvernement
provincial de pour avoir du capital pour
acheter rénover et mettre à disposition
des logements des personnes qui sont en
situation d'itinérance donc
parce que la mission elle-même est pas
capable de payer ça c'est les
gouvernements qui sont capables et
pourquoi la question est simple mais
pourquoi on en fait pas plus
collectivement c'est une excellente
question je n'ai pas la réponse tout ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que les
membres du conseil d'administration avec
qui j'ai le plaisir de travailler eux
ont décidé de s'impliquer pour changer
les choses pour faire pour essayer
d'amener la mission un nouveau niveau à
la déjà connu une bonne croissance mais
malheureusement la demande s'impose à
nous il y a beaucoup de gens qui tombent
en situation d'innéante qui ont besoin
d'aide et notre travail c'est d'essayer
de les aider vous un homme d'affaires
vous avez l'habitude d'avoir des
objectifs qu'est-ce que vous voulez
faire le temps que vous serez à la
mission bon écoutez moi mon ambition ça
serait de réussir à
coordonner le ministère de la Santé avec
le ministère des Affaires municipales et
de l'habitation pour qu'on ait des plans
peut-être plus efficaces pour construire
plus de logements mais ces fonds là
c'est c'est des fonds qui viennent
en ce qui concerne le capital largement
d'Ottawa et en ce qui concerne
l'opération largement de Québec et
l'entreprise privée va faire sa part
mais malheureusement il faut il faut que
le gouvernement est davantage comprenant
aussi un mot tellement important de
coordonner parce qu'on a l'impression
dans ce domaine du logement social
abordable d'urgence
beaucoup d'intervenants et il y a un
espèce de fouillis et malheureusement on
voit pas assez les résultats concrets
assez rapidement
je suis pas en mesure d'évaluer ça non
ce que je sais c'est qu'il y a un besoin
criant en logements sociaux il y a une
démarcation entre
si vous voulez l'appeler qualité
économique mais une marche que des gens
peuvent malheureusement ils vont tomber
ils peuvent être évincés de leur
logement peuvent avoir une crise dans
leur vie peuvent devenir dépendant de
substance ou de jeux ils peuvent avoir
un décès dans la famille ces gens-là
peuvent tomber dans l'itinérance et ça
mais notre travail c'est de les soulager
donc le les gouvernements le message est
très clair les gens d'affaires les gens
d'affaires ont dit que la communauté
anglophone les le monde anglophone
devrait agir
c'est avantages à leurs habitudes de
donner pour ces choses-là vous le
constatez à tous les jours oui mais je
veux pas
insulter personne mais c'est un fait que
les dons moyens des francophones sont à
peu près la moitié du don moyenne d'un
Canadien la moitié ou 40 % là je me
souviens plus du donjon moyen d'un
Canadien anglophone c'est un fait c'est
documenté c'est pas je dis pas ça pour
l'armée personne c'est un état de fait
et c'est une réalité sociale et notre
travail à nous c'est d'essayer
d'expliquer la situation aux gens dans
l'espoir qu'ils vont être généreux avec
nous
c'est tout ce qu'on peut faire louer
Audin vous aviez on s'était on s'était
parlé à ce moment-là vous aviez lancé
cette idée du salaire minimum à 20
dollars en disant les inégalités
sociales économiques sont trop
importantes pas possible que 1 %
est le quart on a sorti de un seul
chiffre 1% des plus riches 25% possèdent
25% des de la richesse 10% 57%, les 50%
les moins riches 5,8%
parce que depuis trois ans l'impression
on aurait dû la pauvreté un peu au
milieu c'est l'extrême pauvreté qui
grandit puis l'extrême richesse
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors d'abord pour
ce qui est du salaire minimum à 20
dollars à l'époque l'idée n'avait pas
été très bien reçue mais le marché s'est
occupé de lever la rémunération des gens
qui étaient insuffisamment à payer alors
de plus en plus le salaire est où ça s'a
maintenant le Canada et le Québec en
général sont des des pays des États où
les inégalités économiques sont moins
élevés qu'ailleurs dans le monde et à
ses voisines de ce qui se passe en
Scandinavie donc on a nous je pense
ici on a un système qui est pas mal bon
mais c'est jamais assez qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour corriger des rêves mais moi
j'ai fait mon petit bout avec un minimum
à 20 dollars c'est tout ça c'est un
autre fondation puis vous vous êtes
généreux c'est un consensus social il
faut un moment donné qui est un
consensus social que
je fais partie du problème moi-même les
plus hauts rémunérés qui ont un salaire
de je sais pas moi 200 fois le salaire
moyen de leurs vous voyez ça peut pas
marcher si vous êtes dans les pays
scandinaves vous allez être à peu près
40 et 60 fois le salaire moyen donc
qu'est-ce que c'est ça ils sont pas
moins bons c'est parce qu'un consensus
social qui s'est établi que c'est comme
ça que la société arménienne c'est comme
ça que ça va fonctionner quand le
message vient d'homme comme vous qui
avez réussi sa porte encore plus que
vous venez de dire
j'espère que vous avez raison très bien
loué Audin merci d'être venu nous voir
dans notre studio on va suivre la
mission all brow et votre vos actions
là-bas à très bientôt merci au revoir
merci